[Musique]
vous arrivez à quelle heure les Chéries
cyil t'a pas prévenu on part pour l
Maurice il nous a fait une surprise quel
salot et ben moi ça me plaît d'être tous
les deux chérie Noël n'est pas là pour
être romantique Noël c'est la fête de la
famille beaucoup de gens sont isolés le
soir de Noël alors pourquoi ne pas
inviter chez vous une personne seule
pourquoi tu veux inviter un vieux chez
nous recevoir quelqu'un qui a plus de
famille c'est unealité non choisis bien
notre invité il est venu me chercher
j'ai pas laasa récupéré un chien mamie
je vous
[Musique]
présente
fr je
pas
plus
[Musique]
plusis
oh c'est du Rome et Monique c'est du
parfum j'en peux plus de Noël je vous en
su faut
[Musique]
arrêterainant on est des Gambiens
batrice des
Gambiens je vais gardé un souvenir
unique de
SNO on passe au cadeau honneur au plus
jeune à vous Vincent non c'est Béatrice
la cadette j'aurais pas dit non mais
c'est normal trois accouchements ça ça
[Musique]
marque